[Music]
hi I'm Emmett whereas Emmett here on
MacDougal Street and so and we
specialize in Chicago style people I
grew up in a suburb of Chicago born and
raised and she worked in the pizzeria
the pizza delivery guy so I was eating
pizza pretty much on a daily basis and
sounded like maybe 16 or 17 years old
when I came to college I went to school
at Fordham University up in the Bronx
yeah I just assumed that we'd be able to
find some type of a Chicago style pizza
here and when I found out that you
couldn't get like a legitimate Chicago
style pizza that's kind of crazy you
know maybe one day I'd want to do that
and the idea just kind of stuck with me
so I started making pizza and just kind
of experimenting with recipes and when I
got the taste that really reminded me
back home I said okay now we're on
something the way we really make our
Chicago pizza is kind of really unique
to my learning experience
do we like doing like a 72-hour for men
so it really kind of gives it like a
nice robust flavor we're using them here
in California vine ripened tomatoes
being that the tenant cooked for about a
half an hour in the oven the tomato is
really sweetened in the oven it's very
much like a heavy blanket of cheese so
you're going to probably see like two or
three times the amount of scenes and if
you just pizza than you would on a you
know a Neapolitan or New York style
inside there's a couple different blends
that we like to put in there that gives
a little bit flavor but primarily
mozzarella cheese it's really like a
slow bake we also cook it 450 degrees
you know a lot of pizzerias especially
looking the apollomon features they're
cooking it like you know a lot of times
over 900 degrees so this is the slow
in Chicago I think our most common and
popular meat topping the sausage really
the nice thing is when the pizza cook
all the fat comes out from the sausage
so you're getting you know not only like
the perfect the perfect bake but you're
getting all the fat coming from the
musasat on we let's hit about three
minutes so you know if I were to cut it
right out of the oven it's so much like
a soup with a molten lava so it gives it
some time to pedal in hard you know
beans from Chicago we have a big sense
of pride and where we're from we were
kind of like the ugly stepchild of pizza
you know as far as like New Yorkers who
want to look at it it's kind of fun
being the underdog you know it's like
being like Daniel in the Karate Kid or
something like that you know the proofs
really in the pudding as far as like you
know you see like a dollar slice pizza
now you're really getting what you pay
for so with us we'd rather kind of
Taylor on the side of using better
quality ingredients and loosen like a
superior product
[Music]